the Honeydew with Ryan sickler
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we
are over here doing a night pass Studios
I'm Ryan sickler Ryan sickle.com Ryan
sickler on all your social media and
again want to thank you guys whether
you're new here whether you've been here
thank you for subscribing thank you for
supporting the special come out and see
me on tour if I'm in your city when
you're available uh tickets are
available at ryancicle.com
um listen if you gotta have more I'm
telling you I say it every week I know
it sounds people like oh it's not a
sales pitch this patreon is five dollars
and it's the Honeydew with you all and
as much as I love sitting across from
comedians athletes whatever
I absolutely love sitting and talking to
you guys alright so we just had a lady
if you haven't heard who uh was almost a
victim of a double homicide or suicide
excuse me murder suicide a double
suicide murder suicide okay Greg
Fitzsimmons is here and um the dude
pulls the gun she Ducks shoots her in
the Carotid artery
then she comes up and he shoots or goes
through her mouth blows open her jaw
outer neck
then he turns the gun on himself kills
himself her mom's in the house sees the
whole thing runs out plugs the Carotid
artery saves her life she's
unfortunately in a wheelchair but she's
alive she looks amazing she is
I mean she's yoked she's got guns and
she's like well when your arms your legs
I was like that's a good point uh but uh
we also just talked to a guy whose uh
grandparents or great aunt Uncle excuse
me were tied up held hostage for six
hours and guess what great uncle got
free 75 years old with a bad hip
killed the guy shot him and killed him
saved his wife High School sweethearts
five dollars y'all sign up for a year
you're getting over a month free all
right uh and if you're looking for an
old podcast or an excuse me a new one to
listen to check out our old podcast the
crab Feast it's Audio Only Greg had
great episodes on there
um and then come see me on tour uh
August 18th and 19th Tampa Florida
September 1st and 2nd Springfield
Missouri September 15th and 16th Tulsa
Oklahoma and I'm adding more and more
dates we're gonna be going out all
through next year all right that's
that's the biz you know what we're doing
here we highlight the low lights and
these are the stories behind the
storytellers I'm very excited to have
this guest back on you know he's here
ladies and gentlemen great fit Simmons
welcome back to the Honeydew young man
let me tell you something
five bucks to hear murder suicides
attempts I mean that is uh that is a
steal Greg we had a guy solve a Cold
Case uh-huh 18-year cold case he
accidentally kicks over a skull he's on
a land survey it's got eyes he freaks
out thinking the murderer is still there
it's a skull he runs out throws up
everywhere they pick the sculpt they
shake it bullet in it still ties back to
the ex-boyfriend they get him for murder
dude wait so you just sit there and
people what stream in their stories
these great fans out here submit at the
Honeydew podcast gmail.com wild stories
we have so many of them send you a video
and then you watch they don't send a
video they'll send me a brief written
description and I'm like would you like
to talk about that more Kirsten works
with them and then boom they zoom in and
so you do the zoom yeah you're gonna
record I love it and we hear the
craziest stories we have a guy who um
this poor dude was born what was it
Kirsten
thank you girl cystic fibrosis so they
basically told him roughly these lungs
are born with you got 50 years on it
well he had to go in for a procedure
back when I was a kid I had a friend who
had it and I was really close with them
my whole life and they said you're not
going to make it to 18 and he died at
16. nowadays they're able to extend it a
lot they made some big breakthroughs in
it
damn yeah this guy was given that long
but he went in for a procedure where
they messed his lungs up so now they
said oops now you only have 25. so he's
desperately in need of a lung donor and
he said to to check all the boxes to get
a double lung transplant is
so many yeah but a friend of a friend of
a friend has a son who's in that same
hospital and he's passing away and she
says
what the hell let's just see if they're
a match and guess what they are dude no
[__] they are so this boy dies his lungs
go in this kid this kid Zooms in with
that guy's lungs tells us this story now
the family wants to meet him
and he's very nervous about meeting them
because I'm the reason your son I'm the
reason I'm alive is because your son's
dead and I've got his lungs so he meets
the family and all his friends and they
start telling them man you look just
like him you sound just like them you're
just like a breathe just like
the mother's like just exhaling my ear
just exhale my ear one time
belch Belch
have an asthma attack we forgot to tell
you he has asthma so they um
they now say we want you to meet his
girlfriend he's like I don't want to
meet her she's going to be emotional I
don't want to meet the girlfriend but he
ends up saying yes because he feels
guilty wait a minute where is this going
you know where it's going no dude took
his lungs and his lady no he did yeah
and now they're married and they just
had a baby he just had a baby
for five dollars
that alone is a 20 story every week yeah
how many of these patreon people do you
have uh we're coming in up on five
thousand let's do it guys we're at like
4 800 let's go 5 000 subscribers on the
patreon yeah these stories are insane
I'm telling you they're insane and I've
kept it five bucks since I've started I
haven't raised it I'm thinking about six
but I don't know I don't know let's get
the 5 000. we'll see but I sit here and
listen every week and I'm I genuinely
say I don't know what we're gonna hear
this time and then
dude's great uncle and Aunt are held
hostage and end up breaking free and
shooting a guy and is there a themes his
stories are just crazy stories it's the
same show that I do with you guys but
with them they highlight their low
lights and I'm saying
these people have you know we just took
our [__] and turned it into being
comedians these people did not yeah you
know yeah yeah they did not do that
right they're like nah this is what
happened they got or they've got
unprocessed ore there's gold in there
I've talked to at least three people
who've died and come back
um I've talked to uh a dude this is one
of the craziest ones uh this guy goes to
is in Philly back when it was open air
like drugs where everyone every corner
he goes oh has that changed yeah a
little bit they hide it now yeah uh and
he goes up and um he gives this guy uh
his money and the guy gives him the
drugs and he turns around walks away
well this residential crack uh head
that's always there is like yo can I get
some he's like no I'm not giving you any
and then he hears the big dude yo hey
and he said immediately he thought oh
[__] I gave him the wrong amount of
money so he turns around now you're the
drug dealer I'm looking at you because I
think oh I [__] up well the crackhead
has snatched a package from the drug
dealer and he turns around and now
crackhead's running directly toward me
drug dealer pulls out a gun boom shoots
crackhead in the back of the head and it
blows all over this guy's face it's in
his mouth it's in his teeth that's
that's some dirty blood
oh and he still went back to his car
with this guy's [__] all over him and
shot up in the car dude it's five
dollars all right enough of my stuff
come on you know my motorcycle died and
came back what my father died hold on
your plugs real quick tell me that well
my father doesn't get your plugs out get
him out I'm gonna write it down I'm not
going to let you get them out in July
I'm going to be coming to you uh in a
town that I'd never heard of it's called
Pottstown and I guess it's west of
Philadelphia Thursday July 20th and then
Friday the 21st I'll be at Uncle
Vinnie's in Point Pleasant New Jersey
which is apparently I mean that's your
neck of the woods right Maryland it's
not far yeah uh but it's I think it's
very Italian it's the shore it's the
[__] sure so Uncle Vinny's the 21st
and 22nd of July and then otherwise just
my podcast is fits dog radio I just had
my thousandth episode a couple weeks ago
thank you thousand episodes 13 and a
half years yeah and uh and then I've got
Sunday papers with Mike Gibbons who you
know and uh we cover the week's news and
then childish which I do with Allison
Rosen so I do three podcasts hell yeah
yeah all right I don't want to miss this
oh yeah so my father so my dad I was an
alcoholic we've talked about that on
this show before and he was driving home
one night
my mom and dad used to go out four
nights a week and they would come home
I'm not exaggerating three four in the
morning they'd be in they'd be in like
nightclubs in New York City
best restaurants in New York City and
they drank their faces off and they
drove home
and so what's with you guys and who was
we had a babysitter you and who else
my brother's a year older my sister's
three years younger okay so you had a
babysitter babysitters love my parents
they made some serious OT and then you
know once you're drunk and it's four in
the morning the money's just flying
so they're driving home from a
restaurant and they're on a deserted
Road and my dad falls asleep behind the
wheel and it's in that station wagon we
were talking about with the rear the
rear facing seat so
falls asleep it's going 40 miles an hour
dead into a big tree damn and uh his
jugular gets cut and his wrist gets cut
by what
if there was no airbags back then I mean
he slammed as a windshield cut yeah I
don't know I was lit all I know is and
your mom's in the car though no cell
phones back then you know this is like
1976. yeah they're probably not wearing
their seat belts even if they were the
seat belts you know they were around
your waist they didn't even go over your
shoulder they just made you pivot
forward harder
[Music]
so my mom has to drive like three miles
to get to town it can still run after
that no she's following him oh I forgot
to mention it okay she's following him
in another car
and so my mom has to drive into town
gets gets the ambulance to come out so
you gotta imagine all this time is going
by he's bleeding out yeah ambulance gets
there he's got no pulse he's flatlined
and they bring him back to life how
since 1976 I don't know what they
[__] had back then you know Band-Aids
and so he was in the hospital for like a
month and I just remember being I was
younger than that I was like six because
I remember not understanding it very
well but then he told me about told me
about going to the other side he
definitely did he have saw the light he
saw the light let go felt light and then
came back what did he feel when he was
coming back that he's ever say that's
what I want to know I know everybody
talks about how it feels when they're
gone
it must feel like when he was at a
letdown it must feel like when you have
a connecting flight across the country
and you finally get to LAX and it's late
and you're but no you're early but the
gate isn't ready oh so now you gotta sit
in the plane with no air conditioning
for 20 minutes
oh [__]
that's crazy
um all right you wanted to share a story
because I wanted we're getting right
into it oh yeah well I like the
embarrassing stuff because it's a little
different than the embarrassing is still
traumatic but it's a little different
and light-hearted than some of the stuff
I sit here and listen to you know and
we've listened to but
um I want to know about this so yeah you
were saying talking earlier I didn't
realize you've been on 50 episodes of
Howard Stern
Ryan
I can't explain my career I am
I've been on Howard Stern 50 times I've
been on I've been in Rogan 22 times
and I can't you fill out for late show
Friday at the Green Bay chocolate like I
don't get it I have had more [__]
exposure here's the thing people have
heard of me they're not buying it
be like that guy he's a good interview
good stand up
not hard on the eyes
not at all but not one of those guys
that with that much exposures playing
theaters
I'm not resentful I always say I crawl
my way to the middle I'm staying right
there yeah nobody's nobody's on my ass
nobody's trying to pull me down I'm not
getting me tooed to like me who this is
no me too you got me
I get mood who's he
so so I get on Stern and the thing you
gotta knows my father was a big radio
guy in New York who's one of the biggest
radio guys in New York City for 20 years
and so but let's let's just for some of
the younger people just so you know like
what years we talk in the 50 episodes
I would say starting in
probably 99. damn really
yeah yeah so you're Prime Stern Prime
Stern he was still on terrestrial when I
started going on just that's pretty
serious
he was on E already yeah but this is but
it's massive massive massive audience
and and but even does Twitter no it
doesn't exist on Twitter so there's no I
mean that's probably a big part of it
too I feel like we're
the getting popular back then before
social media and everything without the
ability to have the exposure and the way
it grows and quickly I feel like we're
sort of like Eric Estrada you know what
I mean like he was that Latin hunk but
yeah right before that JLo burst you
know what I mean he was in that he
missed that window oh yeah yeah here's
the last Ricky Martin and all this
Orchestra I feel like we're punch you
know what I mean yeah strategies Mario
Lopez and he's like can I announce the
movies
can I be the guy that says pretty woman
is on here
yeah I was before
all right so you've got 50 episodes of
that and then you get your own show so
then he gives me my own shell on his
channel and there was a bunch of people
there's a lot of whack Packers there was
um uh Riley uh what's his name Riley
something Riley Martin who would talk to
aliens and ETS and he had a regular
relationship with this planet he was one
of these guys that would like go into
details about the people from overchron
and that they live on this wavelength
and when they talk and he would talk in
their language and he was so crazy and
he was such a drunk but his story was
tight
it's starting to sound like these people
might have been a little more right and
right yeah he might have been on or
something and so Howard would have him
on all the time and he and he would be
so rude to Howard he would always be
like he was his old black guy and he'd
be like man you don't pay me any [__]
money I do all these appearances on your
show and and so finally Howard goes all
right I'll give you your own shell so he
gives him his own show and for an hour
every week they had to go to his house
in New Jersey because he wasn't capable
of getting off the guy he just drank and
they set up shop and they would put him
on the air every week and he would have
callers and uh he would [__] on Howard
every episode so there's all these crazy
shows that were on the network there was
like
you know uh John Hines and Baba Bowie
used to have a show about fast food and
then there was the wrap-up show and so
there was a bunch of there was only a
couple legitimate shows it was me and
then there was a guy named uh
I'm [__] idiot for forgetting his
name but he was a classic radio guy
so
you know
I'm on the air and then so are you
friends would you say your friends
invited me to his house in the Hamptons
and we used to email back and forth more
than just a working room yeah 50 times
on the show it was crazy you know and he
but the reason I bring up my dad is so
he used to [__] on my dad because you
know Howard's MO is just go after
everybody who's above you you know and
that's what he did on the way up
so he stood on my dad said oh this guy's
a has been he hosted Jerry Lewis
Telethon only a husband would host the
Telethon and and so he was Persona
non-grad in my house like my parents did
when my mother especially really
couldn't stand still oh my father kind
of got it he saw what he was doing he
was like all right that's a shtick you
know and so
go to whatever the year was it was maybe
1998 99 and I went to the Aspen Comedy
Festival number HBO used to have a
college I sure do yeah back when Aspen
was a thing yeah so it was fun as [__]
you fly into Aspen you ski
um and so I won I won the the um
Festival they gave me a trophy for Best
comedian at the festival you know why
nobody knows no social media back then
right but I mean everywhere right I
could have gotten some traction on that
[__] right now and so Sophia was not
even around anymore it's Max now that
festival's long gone HBO's gone and so
uh so they so I get on Stern's radar
because they're looking for new people
to come on the show
so they bring me in and I get nervous
because my agent says yeah Howard Stern
called he wants you to come on and my
only connection is he used to [__] on my
father he's going to bring me on why did
he used to [__] on your dad real quick
but just because what connection did
they have well they were both New York
radio guys that's the okay you've been
around longer but had your dad ever had
any animosity okay so it was just
starting we used to go after Don Imus
used to go after William B Williams he
had the funeral he would do funerals for
everybody yeah and down in Philly he
went after John de bella that's one yeah
I did his Show recently uh one tour last
year I love that guy the Bell is the
best yeah he's great and so uh last time
I was in town he wasn't on that week he
was off and he drove to the radio
station because I was doing Preston and
Steve and he picked me up and took me
out to breakfast Stern no uh oh develop
yeah so anyway
so he used to go after my dad and so now
I'm thinking this is some kind of a
hatch job he's gonna bring me on he's
going to attack me he's gonna grab for
my dad but meanwhile when my dad died
Stern did a very serious eulogy did a
very long tribute to my dad he talked
about what he learned from him how in a
business where nobody everybody's
backstabbing whatever that my dad was
the one guy everybody liked it was very
sweet oh yeah so I sort of thought
thought like all right that's fine I'm I
got my piece with him but I'm still
thinking when he when I get on the show
like I don't know how this is gonna go
so then you know for sure if he knows
your the connection yet nope okay and so
okay the night before I don't sleep I
don't sleep oh I forgot a little detail
so I'm listening and I was a fan I used
to listen to the show yeah so I think
it's a big show there's a lot of anxiety
going on with this whole layer of your
dad there yeah so I'm going on on a
Monday Friday is a they were on a
vacation week and they played a rerun
and on the rerun he's [__] on my
father
so now I'm like oh this is a [__]
setup
so I go in and you still go you don't
puss out [__] [__] yeah
I figured if you went after me I was
gonna go back at him just as hard you
know
I knew stuff about them
so yeah you probably did have some
insight that other people oh yeah yeah
they had the same agent my father and
and Howard Don buckwalt
so I go in and uh he immediately
welcomes me with open arms sings my my
father's Praises oh [__] love song to
my dad
treats me great and I see that like he's
got kids and he sees something in me and
he's fascinated I swear to God a dozen
times when I was on a show he would ask
me what it was like having a father who
was a famous radio guy because he wanted
to know what it was like for his kids I
see okay and he also just there was just
this thing where I felt like he loved me
I really did you know it was a very
close connection and obviously being on
the sh and off the air he is the kindest
person the most generous person you've
ever met nothing like what he's on like
on air and so you know between during
commercial breaks we would huddle up and
talk [__] and gossip and and so
um so I did the show like 50 times and
then um any and then at a certain point
he goes uh hey do you want your own show
we're on the air he's like you want your
own show on the channel and I was like
yeah yeah I would love that this is how
he drops it yeah isn't it blow you away
like I've talked about people a lot of
times about like when something an
opportunity like that happened and in
your mind when you're a kid and you try
to dream of these things or yeah yeah
yeah you don't [__] it just it's not
like that's how that happened you know
what I mean a friend of mine got a movie
role one time and I was like what were
they doing when they told you oh he was
gathering his stuff to go swimming I'm
like swimming right your life's hanging
in the balance right right so right
there he's like you want to show on this
network you want a show on the network
and uh you know and they give me a they
get a studio in Hollywood but then they
also set me up I have a guest house in
the back and they wired it with these
ISDN lines which are like high speed
cable for radio and they buy me tons of
equipment and they hire a producer and
an assistant and it was real legit you
know last year so you're able to do it
here okay and then I would and then they
had a studio in Hollywood sometimes I'd
drive in and do the studio in Hollywood
and um and it goes great and he's
constantly going on the air the day
after my show was Monday nights and he
would go on Tuesday Mornings a lot of
times he'd play clips for my show oh man
great
so after 10 years of this I write a book
I write a memoir Dear Mrs Fitzsimmons
Tales of redemption from an Irish
mailbox and it was letters that my
mother had received my whole life when I
was in trouble principals teachers
police reports from the times I'd gotten
arrested you had all that stuff yeah
yeah clippings from the paper when I got
arrested and she had it all in a shoebox
and I founded my aunt's basement in the
Bronx and I was like this is [__]
Creek she saved this it was like a
trophy case because we're Irish they
always thought it was funny
I would get in trouble and then we'd be
having dinner that night and my my
mother would read the letter like oh my
like I remember one was my um art
teacher in in sixth grade was named
Dewey echdoll and so we used to do jokes
about Dewey you know just stupid like
hey Mr act all do we have any homework
tonight hey the grass was really dewy
this morning Mr echdoll uh just stupid
jokes anyway so he wrote it up and he
listed all the jokes and my parents read
it at dinner and they were [__] done
so that was how rebellion was treated in
my family and so I said this is a book
I'm just gonna write a book and each
letter I'm gonna in that chapter I'm
gonna explain what was happening during
that letter
and and it ended up going way deeper
because I started to sort of Peel back
layers on my relationship with my dad
and where this Rebellion came from where
this anger came from where why was I
fist fighting all the time and so I went
deep into some [__]
and uh
and so anyway so I was really proud of
this book it meant a lot to me and so I
was with Simon Schuster and they said
you got to get somebody to write it
forward
and so I thought it's got to be Howard
you know it would have been my dad but
he's gone I'll ask Howard to do it so I
write up this note
and uh
I
I send it in no I was in New York so I
handed it to the program director Tim
Sabian and I said will you give this to
Howard and uh and it was it said Howard
uh you've been like a mentor to me
um I had no pressure I totally
understand if you can't do it but it
would mean a lot to me if you wrote the
forward to my book
so Tim Sabian I don't realize this
Howard [__] hates being asked to do
things like this like for whatever
reason I wasn't really aware of how much
he hated this kind of stuff so Tim
Sabian is very aware of it so Tim on
Monday morning puts it on Howard's
microphone the note
and Howard comes in starts the show and
he goes what the [__] is this opens it
up and reads the letter on air no right
it was like a lot of heartfelt stuff was
kind of gushy and so he goes what the
[__] am I gonna write Greg fitzsimmons's
forward for I mean Greg who the [__] is
he to ask I could be playing chess I
could be [__] my wife I could be
watching Lost like what and I'm gonna be
writing a four so so like I hear this
and I'm like [__] he goes I'll do it but
I I don't know why I'm [__] doing
this and so
um he calls me and I'm in La so my phone
rings and it's like it's my home phone
so it's like you know it's
like 5 a.m L.A time oh Jesus hello
hey now
he's like what the figures why are you
asking me to write a forward to well how
I just thought you know I said you don't
have to do yeah but you do you so it
goes into a whole thing
and then he basically goes let me off
the hook on this I go Howard I never put
you on the hook I go the note said you
don't have to do this I go there's no
understand don't say there's a hook that
I put you on and so he calls back you
know the next day he's trash talking
this goes on and I am getting hate mail
from the viewers because now there's
social media and people are you know his
army of people oh yeah just love to pile
on people and it and I'm not that guy I
don't deal well with hate on social
media at this point I don't do a lot of
things he continues even after that
conversation you're still doing it he
made a bit out of it and I even emailed
him at one point and I went Howard hey I
just want to make sure we're cool I'm
not sure if this is a bit or oh yeah
Greg no it's it's totally fine you know
next day so [__] Greg Fitzsimmons
emails me yesterday
and he goes hey I just want to make sure
we're cool yeah like and and it just and
I my stomach was in a bit plus I'm so
nervous my book is coming out I'm trying
to line up the Press tour and uh and it
was just such a huge distraction and it
was so gut-wrenching
to have this person who I looked up to
so much who I considered a friend
to use me
it part of it was he was using it as a
radio bit part of it was he really was
angry that I asked him
and
do you think you would have been as
angry if it wasn't just tented over his
microphone like that no Sabian [__] me
Tim Sabian [__] like in in Howard's mind
did you set that there
no okay no but Sabian absolutely could
have been a filter it was like just a
heads up man he hates doing this yeah
[__] yep
and that's the thing about that world
everybody's pushing each other in front
of the bus every day
they tape record each other they prank
each other do they really they [__] talk
each other they fight on the air and
it's like I always went in there and
somehow I got treated with kid gloves
Howard never [__] on me not once did he
go after me I saved it up though didn't
he yeah Jesus yeah so for a month
month and a half month and a six weeks
are you listening every [__] oh yeah
and it's daily wasn't it daily right
it's not weekend and then there's all
these blogs it's all these blogs where
they write down like what was said on
the show that day
oh Reddit
threads and
it was humble it was so hurtful and you
know and I still I still you know Howard
still means a lot to me and I still
listen to the show so wait when did it
stop and why did you reach out again
I think I only went on the show Once
after that oh you went on maybe maybe
twice once twice I just you know here's
the thing is he said to me when I first
started going on they started bringing
me in regularly and then Jackie The Joke
Man left the show so they called it
Jackie's chair because Jackie's chair
was the guy who sat in
jokes for the news bits right stuff for
Howard and so that was essentially what
we would do when we'd come in and so
they decided they were going to replace
Jackie's chair and so they started
having a lot of comedians come in
Stanhope did it a lot already did it a
lot I did a lot he started weeding
people down
all of a sudden like it's in the papers
like it's down to Greg Fitzsimmons and
already lying for for Jackie's chair
okay they're like covering it like it's
a horse race and then you know
rightfully so already got the chair I
could have I could have done 10 of what
already did he would come in on Monday
morning from Vegas after having sex with
a hooker who he thought was just a girl
he was [__] until she charged him the
next morning you know crazy stories
betting on games he can't afford the
losses on and meanwhile I'm married with
two little kids what am I what am I
gonna bring to the show and Artie's also
a dear friend so I was very happy for
him and every time I came on the show me
and Arty would go out to eat at The
Brooklyn Diner next door every single
time and uh and so when I didn't get
Artie's chair Howard said to me
anytime you want to come on the show the
door is open and he was true to that I
like every time I called I emailed Gary
said like I'm in town next week and I
come in coming on Tuesday it was like it
was like that
and then uh and then I came in once or
twice after that happened and then they
kind of changed the format and now the
show is more like Jennifer Aniston today
and [__] Elton John the next day and
Billy Joel and the show is only on three
days a week instead of five
three hours a day instead of five so
there's less real estate and much bigger
names so I just kind of faded out of it
like a lot of guys did well what was it
like the first episode back did you
address anything did he bring it up what
was that like didn't bring it up were
you worried that was an ambush too yeah
you were yeah I would definitely be
worried about that one yeah he didn't
even bring it up I think they allowed
one caller who gave me [__] that's
happening that's how they do it they
always go they're like like he'll have
on like you know Gwyneth Paltrow or
somebody who's very ariadite educated
and then you know because because
Howard's two questions are always have
you had a lesbian experience and have
you had anal every woman on the show
gets asked that so he has Gwyneth
Paltrow he can't ask her that uh we got
we got bill from Boston on yeah Gwyneth
you ever take it in the pulpa and then
how we go come on this is Gwyneth
Paltrow here but but Gwyneth the did you
like that was always the move
yeah is thinning hair holding you back
nutriful is here to help their physician
formulated hair growth supplements and
scalp care products create a simple but
effective routine to address thinning at
the source
when your scalp is unbalanced or not
careful regularly with the right
products it can become clogged dry and
irritated leading to a poor environment
for natural hair growth neutrophils
physician formulated scalp care products
are clinically shown to balance the
scalp and visibly improve hair health
and strength in two weeks with their 100
natural fragrance zero parabens and
ingredients that are color and extension
safe neutralfold supplements are the
foundation for healthy hair growth while
the scalp care products create an
environment for hair to thrive with just
a simple daily routine these formulas
set you up for your healthiest hair yet
take the first step toward improved hair
and scalp Health now for a limited time
neutropholes offering our us listeners
ten dollars off your first scalp care
order when you go to neutrophone.com
scalp and enter promo code honeydew find
out why over 4 000 Health Care
Professionals recommend neutrofoil for
healthier Hair
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l.com slash scalp and
enter promo code honeydew for ten
dollars off your first scalp care order
this is available only to us customers
for a limited time that's nutrifold.com
scalp promo code honeydew for ten
dollars off your first scalp care order
now let's get back to the do
so and then you go on again and it's
good enough it's fine and
email still
but net he never brought it up after
that just sort of like it never happened
he kind of well you know I think it
faded the bit but don't you think that's
odd though to put something in six weeks
worth of like this guy doing this then
it's a bit it's a bit to me
a good [__] usually a two-way bit I
feel like you know what I mean not well
the bid was kind of you don't want to
you know I kind of made it a bit as well
because I kept saying I'm not taking you
off the hook you can you can say I don't
want to do this but I'm not going to
resent rescind my request because I feel
like my request came from a place of
respect and a place that gave you an
option to say no
and instead of off the air saying thank
you for requesting this is not something
I like doing no offense done
did you ever say anything to his
producer
no no
so when you was your father alive when
you were working for stern
no no but your mom was my my mom was my
father died in 93 and this would have
been around 99 and my mother was not
happy I want yes to this day not happy
that I went on Stern she was like you
know she always felt like my father
could have gone further in his career
and that you know he she really thought
like he should have been the host of
tonight's show you know that's how she
felt about her husband sure you know
like her I would hope my wife thinks
about me tell you you know and so the
fact that this guy was bad-mouthing my
dad
there was never going to be you even no
matter what he said after he died
nothing was going to bring him back for
that and to me it was more like look I
get what Howard does I I like it to some
extent does he go too far sometimes yes
but you know I walked in there with my
eyes open yeah this is a guy who had
done it to my father
why wouldn't he do it to me
how did you tell your mom
that I was going on Stern or did you not
oh no no I told him no we had it we had
a discussion and uh you know she
she she never my mother's very past
Progressive so she'd find ways of
bringing it up there were little [__]
digs to me you know but I know that she
thought my father was rolling in his
grave that I was on on the third show
yeah yeah do you think he would be do
you think he'd be scared no I think my
father would get it he get it I mean
look it was the literally the biggest
Outlet in broadcasting when he was at
his Peak
yeah he was on how many stations across
the country and these are all cities
that I'm doing stand-up in yeah and he
would do my plugs and I would sell out
every show in that market
so if I had like you know three weeks of
shows coming up in a row I would fly to
New York and it was always on my dime I
flew myself in I put myself up they
didn't pay me great Trade Fair Trade I
mean yes take the plugs it was a blast
doing it
um I loved that staff of people Gary's
one of the nicest people ever met John
Hines and
um they're they're all they're all
really well they're they're great people
and they're a lot of fun and they
treated me with a lot of respect and I
and I I love my time there was your mom
still alive when he [__] on you for the
six weeks yes yeah what happened then
did she give you and I told you so or
um get more fired up about that because
that probably didn't see yeah yeah he's
doing it to my husband yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I think it
I think it hurt her she was upset by it
and then when he wrote the forward he
wait so he did end up writing a forward
he wrote the forward
[Laughter]
he did not sit down with a pen and paper
and write the forward he was on the air
and he goes all right
why don't we just do this I'll write the
forward right now let's let's do it and
he goes uh gutsy Greg Fitzsimmons is a
great guy uh Greg Fitzsimmons is better
than I forget what he said but he just
said just crazy [__] off the top of his
head and somebody transcribed
transcribed it
and then he said he also demanded that
his wife's picture be in the forward so
the first page of my book
is a photo of his wife Beth yeah yeah
who's a beautiful woman but
front page in my book
and then the foreign
at this point and Simon shoes is like
you're putting a forward for Howard
Stern that's gonna sell but and I never
thought about it like oh this is gonna
help sell books I just thought about it
like I want this book to be something
that lives forever that my kids read and
that is seen as like you know uh who I
am as a person and I really felt like a
big part of my career I mean things
happen in my career that never would
have happened if I hadn't been on Howard
Stern development deals hosting jobs
stand-up gigs like it all came from
there for years so I wanted to represent
that
and uh so he wrote it very off the top
of his head it was humorous and at the
very end he said something very sincere
but it was uh
if I could do it all over again I would
ask you to write the four it's my book
that's what he said no I would say I'm
saying that to you right now are you for
real yeah I would write the foreign
I would love that I'm touched yeah I
thought you were saying that was what he
said no no no no no no
no I would fight I would find somebody
who I respect and who I know respects me
and I would just say you know just write
something from the heart that's it dude
I would definitely write your report
it's not gonna sell any [__] books it
ain't gonna sell one book all right what
if your patreon included as part of your
patreon you get a book with the five
bucks a month
man what a weird [__] thing too life
is so strange your dad you you didn't
have to become anything in the public
eye after your father already was you
know what I mean the fact that you do
and even though it's different it's
still it's not radio and it still ends
up driving right into the lane where you
work with the dude that [__] on your dad
yeah and then he does that to you who
gives me a radio show yeah that gives
you what is what your father had yes
following your Father's Footsteps and
then treat you for six weeks the way he
treated your father yeah right
that's [__] it's crazy that is crazy
but you know what it I I got over it
pretty quickly you know because the book
did well and do you think that Ford
helped do you know if it did I don't
know because the same week that my book
came out Gary
delabate's book came out the same week
and so did Adam carolla's book and wrote
those forwards who wrote Gary's Ford
not Howard no no I don't think so I have
to saw your [__] he's like
six weeks of this [__] yeah
and I don't know that I think Adam
writes his own forwards
he asked somebody else to write the form
but while they're starting to say it he
writes it for them
so
yeah I got over it pretty quickly and uh
and I don't have I have no bad feelings
towards Howard
um I still listen to the show you know
it would I wouldn't be able to listen to
the show if I had any resentments yeah
you know
what um give me some other embarrassing
moments you ever have any embarrassing
let's go back to like Middle School you
ever have any middle school or High
School
when I was right away all right when I
was about
nine
it was the first time you started to be
aware of girls like she's pretty and
there was uh it wasn't my friend's name
was uh Brian Tompkins
it was one of seven kids
George Ernie Timmy Billy Brian Genevieve
and Liz okay and uh we were friends with
their family and Liz was I'm sure still
is absolutely beautiful woman and the
nicest person smile crazy body I'm seven
and I already get it I get Liz Tompkins
is hot
so I'm friends with Brian
and uh how old's Liz at the time you're
seven she's what no no I think maybe I'm
nine I'm nine she's like probably 13 or
14.
and
so we went to Brian's house and we had
been swimming in a pool and so we went
into Brian's room and I was changing out
of my bathing suit and I was completely
naked and right out of the pool too with
that little pool dick no and it's nine
to begin with yeah it's a nine-year-old
fresh out of the pool fresh out of the
pool bro I mean that's before I don't
even know if the nut sack had fallen at
that point it might still be up in the
valley yeah all tight and then Brian
flipped open the door
so Liz could come in and Liz walked in
and saw me
and
I cried no
Pride
it was like literally having a nightmare
in your real life
because that's your nightmare ever
the nightmare that they're naked and
they're walking down the street
two things that are happening to me
right now first of all you say nightmare
like Bert Kreischer I've been told that
I just heard it three times and second
of all we're gonna come back to this in
a second but
is that how you have to come now
weeping
shame I'm not gonna lie to you I have
shame she saw it and you just started
crying and then she didn't even leave
she kept talking she kept going it's no
big deal it doesn't matter oh she's
trying to make you feel better about it
the best she could yeah best she could
have done was leave the [__] room
yeah instantly yeah she didn't laugh or
anything though no no holy [__] she
probably also you got to think of this
too now let's look back you said one of
seven yeah she's probably seen her she's
seen it yeah yeah her brothers all have
big brothers yeah they're right you know
those kids are all running around the
house after a shower she's seen plenty
of little dicks at that age yeah you
were good dude I do I'm not good at
nudity in front of people are you no I
um no I've never been great at that what
about in a men's locker room man now see
because I go I'll tell you a couple
stories but how old are you now
57. all right so you're I'm 50. so when
we were in Middle School
and we I still am very tight friends
with three or four guys maybe more than
that for Middle School where we talk
about it in sixth grade all of a sudden
it was gym class and in gym class we put
on the shirt white was a white shirt
with a little box here you put your last
name in red shorts little white box you
put your last name yeah but after Jim
you have to take your uniform off and
put it in a locker and it was a
mandatory shower oh no wait
we're in sixth grade
sixth grade and so you don't even have
pubes yet you're 12. you're you're
you're you're hitting sixth to eighth
grade you're starting to just get cubes
everything's starting to have the Latino
kids have a full Bush got a big this kid
Marlo Woodyard I'm gonna tell you right
now he had he was our age he had a 30
year old man's dick really it was just
unbelievable wow and so something like
that and you're like
you know like is that what it's supposed
to look like no so
but what was strange it was communal
had wall and had a middle one here and
the the
um gym teachers would stand that one
teacher would stand at the door yeah
make you go in naked you had to at least
get wet most kids would run in get their
back under that [__] and get it
and we were like why why did we have to
do that yeah if you haven't hit anybody
you don't smell yet also but why is
there a teacher standing here watching
all of us underage boys right because
he's a PE teacher what are you talking
about so I've always been uncomfortable
starting with that I never have ever
ever showered at a public gym like when
I go work out yeah nope never never when
I go to these Burke Williams places I've
gone a couple times I hate getting in
the pool naked but I've done it yeah but
I'm not comfortable doing it yeah
do you
when I used to work out there's there's
a place in New York called Chelsea Piers
and I lived like two blocks away and it
was state of the art it was before
high-end gyms existed it was one of the
first you know gyms that has like the
Spa the pool yeah gymnastics area boxing
gym a track that goes around the store
it was like a three block long it had
trampolines it had a golf range next to
it damn so I was a member and when I
joined it was cheap because they just
opened so I was paying like 100 bucks a
month and I would go there five days a
week I [__] loved ice hockey rink I
played in the hockey league oh [__] yeah
with Tim Robbins and Ian bag were on my
team yeah why this exist anymore
I think it's still there yeah oh it's
definitely still sounds yeah I'd be
there all the time just so much to do
not just regular old weights and I would
work out and then I would go into the
steam room
and uh but you know I'd wear a towel
yeah but some guys didn't wear a towel
and so I walk into the steam room one
day and I got my towel on and I sit down
and you know it's at the it's at the the
low end where the steam is falling out
of the air and it's a and you realize
and there's a guy sitting across from me
and you realize there's a big difference
between hanging out in a steamy room
with some naked guys and sitting alone
in a space this big with a naked man
just one other one just one other one
and so I'm not really looking I'm not
I'm not really looking at them I'm kind
of peering at them and then I kind of go
like I think that guy looks [__]
familiar and so look I look hard
Lou Reed now Lou Reed Take a Walk on the
Wild Side
naked and his old dick is hanging down
and I and I knew he worked out there
because his wife was Lori Anderson and
she was famously with swim laps in the
pool so he's sitting in there with his
dick out and there's no Steam and he
finally just shakes his head and he
stands he says something to me and he
stands up and he walks out naked what
does he say it's just something like uh
this is taking forever whatever nothing
and he walks out
and then as soon as the door closes
no hell yeah Steve starts coming out
yeah so my reaction was I opened the
door to say hey
come on and I just pictured myself in a
towel waving a naked man
like the first scene of a gay porn right
and all I saw was his saggy ass cheeks
walking away and I just and I just let
him go I let him walk away didn't say a
word
dude I went one time I've told the story
once somewhere I think I'll tell it to
you because you'll you'll get this so I
wanted to go do a Burke Williams day and
I had a writing job at this place and
all the ladies kept telling me that
place is a rip-off go down to Koreatown
oh yeah it's the same thing for way
cheaper Paulie sure goes there five days
a week to the ones in Koreatown yeah
okay so okay let me tell you where I
went so I go to this place and it's like
off of Wilshire good area yeah yeah
there's a golf range Outback and all
this stuff and I'm like huh all these
ladies have told me to go there
so I go in and I mean they don't speak
English at all like nothing I don't even
know how to I'm I'm I've never been I
don't know what to do and they're just
doing the put the [__] paper what do
you point what do you want I might want
that whatever
so
um they just give me like this robe and
I'm like is someone gonna come get me
and the lady just said you'll figure it
out but it's very broken English you
figure it out so I go back
I part these beads
it's the gayest place I've ever been in
my life I mean 800 dicks might as well
just beat me in the face when I walked
through I was like
so I get what they're saying but they go
to the female so this isn't co-ed like
Burke Williams and you just go here and
here this is all dudes and it's all gay
dudes yeah and I am fresh meat up in
that place and I go in and I'm like oh
whatever you know what I'm just gonna do
I'm uncomfortable in in a place where
I'm not looked at the way I'm being
looked at and I'm like whatever this is
a good exercise and you know being a man
about this and whatever no biggie I go
out there I swear to God great but
Simmons I walk up the steps
okay you're not you ain't wearing trunks
over here yeah and this Adonis is just
laying on the side chatting up this dude
and his dick it's dipping in the water
off the side it's dipping and I'm like
this all right it's always that one guy
yeah it's Max wow it's a hose no I'm
like and it's like how do you not look
at that I'm like God God so I'm like nah
so then um I go to get a massage they
say You're Gonna something masseuse is
gonna come get you I'm still expecting a
lady to come get me but a guy comes this
old dude comes and gets me is he Korean
yeah everybody's Korean yeah except for
the men in there and I realize this
they're not [__] here but they're
definitely making an appointment to go
[__] later
they're all talking to each other you
know what I'm saying like we're not
gonna [__] in here because we're like
but this is their this is the showroom
this is the bar to go meet or whatever
this is what these guys like
so the guy comes and gets me and he
takes me to an open room if Paulie Shore
goes these places it's an open room it's
probably 10 tables long
there's maybe who knows there's one
other guy in there it might have been
Paulie Shore he's about eight tables
down this dude puts me on a table face
down and at first I'm like what if I've
never got I've only gotten an erection
one time from a massage and it's it was
an old Asian lady yeah and she didn't
even touch me she did this thing with
the bed sheet she's kept pulling it
tight across my dick like this really
yeah she knew what she was doing she was
popping it like this and it would just
kept pressing down on my dick and my
dick started fighting back you know what
I mean never even sexually touched me or
anything
and I was like some old secret right
there yeah
strap on that [__] and uh I'm like what
you know I'm starting to think like what
if I get hard from this massage
so I put my face down in the table and
this dude steps underneath with his
flip-flops and I see his toenails and my
dick's like we're good
we're good to go bro I'm gonna take a
nap now here I promise
and you got that image oh whenever you
need it yeah you pull it up again man
and then they just start aggressively
scrubbing your body just loofing your
body and exfoliating and then they just
take a like a five gallon bucket from
Home Depot and splash all the exfoliated
skin off you onto this floor they're not
hosing this floor they're not doing
anything this place is massive so now he
says get up and go shower well I go to
shower
it's like three showers right here and
on this side it's the room's not bigger
than this on this side three recliners
lined up perfectly for someone to sit
there and watch oh there's no stalls
it's just it's just a space yeah
go over there and you're showering naked
now you're naked because you're in the
massage and there's guys in robes
watching I was like I'm gonna get the
[__] out of here so I go back and now
I'm just like these [__] ladies at
work man I [__] I knew I shouldn't
have listened I should have just gone to
Burke Williams in the first place so
it's Mother's Day and the reason I was
like this is the only time I'm gonna get
to go do this so my daughter's with her
mom I go to do this on Mother's Day I
drive to Burke Williams all the way from
downtown to Santa Monica yeah
and I ring the thing and they tell me
that they're closed to Men on Mother's
Day it's women only
and I said y'all do that on Father's Day
yeah they're like what I'm like well do
you shut the salon down for anyone but
men that go no I was like that is [__]
up yeah and it was another three months
before I go get a massage it was so
dissatisfying it was nothing it made me
more anxious ah you've been to those
salons
there's a place in Portland Oregon
called the Elliott House not already I'm
already a big nope on the house in there
it's a house it's a it's a big old
Victorian house
and I was told by my friend no I I go in
I think my friend told me it's a good
place to get a massage
and so I go in and I get this great
massage you know it's like a hippie
dippy a lot of beads a lot of incense
and
um very sweet everybody's nice and then
I come out and I'm paying and the lady
goes oh we should let you know we also
have a spa if you want to go in there
it's just an extra 10 bucks and we've
got steam and sauna Whirlpool the whole
thing and uh that sounds good she goes I
should let you know it's clothing
optional and I was like
well what option do people generally go
with
she's like it's nude it's nude so
I stopped for a second and I'm like I
got a lot of body image issue I was a
really skinny kid I was the palest kid
in town freckles
[__] just red orange pubic hair
did you skinny ass legs yeah orange
people care and uh you know and I and
I'm at now when I go redhead I was a
redhead you were yeah okay now I got
little tits me too yeah you know and I'm
just thinking to myself all right this
might be an opportunity to overcome
these body issues that I still because
I'm not that skinny anymore my body's
actually just right now filled out 150
pounds
you're [__] right
yeah hell yeah wherever you got there
bro is that how you start it's how you
work leave a pretty corpse
and so
I go yeah I'm gonna do it so they uh
they give me a robe and they go going to
the locker room I don't know what the
robe is for but I go down there I put
the robe on and then as I'm standing
there
two naked women walk by and and I start
seeing a lot of naked people in the
background and this is Portland naked
these are women they're
they're good looking bodies but muffs
like 70s style there's no shaving in
Portland
they're growing it out they're putting
Rogaine on their crotch it's running
down the legs and so I was like so I
said I just took it off and I was like
you know what I'm gonna be free I'm
gonna be free and so I put the robe in
the locker and I walk in and I within 30
seconds
I felt the air on my whole naked body
and I kind of owned it and I felt really
empowered by it and then I went into the
steam room
and so I'm sitting in the same room and
it's steamy but at the same time you can
see you can still see people but not
that well like I'm look like and I don't
want to stare because I'm the oldest guy
by two decades easily and so I'm already
the creepy guy in the going like
and so I don't want to stare at anybody
so I'm just like peering out of the
corner of my eye and I see something in
the corner and you know
could be a tit could be a guy's shoulder
I'm not really sure but I'm looking at
it yeah and then uh and then and then
and then this guy walks in and he's the
guy he's the guy from your place he's
got on a man bun shoulders back and he
is swinging a steak big steak
flopping back and forth and you know
like and and he just he and he sits down
and yeah man spreads and and then this
girl gets up on the wood
and then the balls
and so then this girl gets up and she
starts doing yoga poses totally naked
doing yoga I'm just sitting there going
this is the greatest [__] decision I
ever made in my life
amazing and so uh and so then I was like
it was January and there was like a
light rain going on so it was cold and
rainy and I wanted to go in the hot tub
but the hot tub was in the backyard
which was like you know outside like it
was outside like a good 10 15 yards out
and so I'm thinking to myself all right
I'm naked I'm my my girth is good first
of all you should know I have a good
sized penis I have a big penis great go
for you usually the skinny guys do have
the big dicks is that right that's what
I always feel like I it's
tall skinny guys I know you're not tall
but usually the lanky dudes got the big
deal well I um I had sex with a few a
few yeah so my stepson he's six five all
right skinny [__] he's probably got it I
think Pete Davidson is known for having
him that's what I'm saying guys it built
like the Michael Phelps prize got a
hammer on them you know guys he's got a
tall lanky Ari shaffir
I don't know he pulled it out on camera
that one time it didn't look no offense
oh he pulled it out on my podcast I
wouldn't have pulled that out yeah you
pulled it out on your pocket he did well
we were zooming from New York and we did
the entire podcast hour and 15 minutes
and then he goes all right man thanks a
lot for having me on he stands up and he
had no pants or underwear the entire
time
ah
that's great
so so I go all right so my girth is good
and I'm like all right but I gotta get
to that hot tub and that means walk in
about 15 Paces in freezing rain and that
may not be good and there's a bunch of
people in there and so I I was like you
know I'll be fine two steps in and it
just disappears like the cold rain hits
it and it was like all the flesh just
went right back into my body like it was
no shaft
it was just like it was just like
sitting on your balls
like a bald guy with hairy shoulders
just just sitting there angry and so I
run to the hot tub and then I realized
like the hot tub is like an in-ground
hot tub so now as I'm getting in
everybody's eye level is with my Acorn
deck running right out yeah so I jump in
the water how many people are in there
it was like six or seven women yeah yeah
it's not just you running to get in so I
get in and I and and I got that that hot
stream is is hitting my lower back and I
kind of turn to the side I start getting
a little getting a little hot
that's a stream going on my balls flesh
out again but I was like I'm not getting
out of this [__] hot tub until
everybody's like I'm hard I waited till
late no I waited till everybody oh and
while I was in there the guy with the
man bun comes in he walks through the
cold I think it made it bigger you see
he got it splashed water is flying off
the sides
[Music]
that's all too dude it was just swaying
like an elephant Jump by itself that's
right just like yeah no this is how I am
yeah yeah like Jesus Christ dude how do
you hang
I'm all right you know what I mean I'm
you know I don't usually I don't have to
talk about I like my dick yeah I like it
I've had no complaints about it yeah you
know my friends got a micro penis I
don't have a I definitely don't have a
microphone yes Paul Lyons he wrote an
article about I'm not shouting because
you wrote an article about it in uh
Playgirl magazine which was very funny
he's a really smart funny guy and uh
he's loves being nude he he goes to like
my friend was with him in Martha's
Vineyard and Martha's Vineyard has
beaches that are nude and then family
beaches oh I didn't know that I know
they had new beaches yeah so he goes out
to the nude beach and he immediately
takes off all his clothes and and he's
just walking around and my friends like
I couldn't believe it like like there's
no dick it's like literally no dick yeah
what let's describe micro here we
talking about like an inch well it's
like what we said no it's like just
Crown it's like crown on balls yeah
and that's hard I don't know what it's
like hard what if it goes nine inches
well if he's like I'm a grown man
like a telescope because contact
telescope yeah
so then they go back to the family beach
and Tom's like put your clothes on he's
like no I'm not going to be told what to
do and he's like walking past little
kids with the micro dick
see that's another one you'd have to
look at yes you gotta look at that you
can even talk to the guy about that
because he he's putting it out there for
discussion yeah right yeah right
yeah no thank God no I like my dick I
have a nice dick we're friends I mean
you have to have a good relationship
with your dick you really do yes you're
beating a thing yeah you know what I
mean like still I don't care no one
touches me the way I touch me right you
know what I mean yeah I can knock one
out in a minute if I have to no like if
I have to if I get fired up and I'm like
I gotta get this out of here it'll be no
problem self minute no problem is that
with video
yeah yeah yeah what's your category I'm
listen that's the other thing I don't I
don't really discriminate now I'll go
through the feed first see what fear
feed
I started
[Laughter]
you know you're done when it's a hair
clip yeah
dude thank you for coming on it's been a
fun episode I can't believe it's over
it's over bro can I come on a patreon
would you really want to I'll do
anything if you want to sit next to me
and listen to these stories I'm signing
up for the patreon it's so unbelievable
everybody should these people I'm
telling you again wait please plug and
promote everything again please uh fits
dog radio which uh you know you have
different guests every week I just had
Paulie shore on uh last night hell yeah
he was great
such a good interview
um I just said Zach Galifianakis on
recently okay uh that was for the
thousandth episode that was a big one
and uh yeah a lot of great guests Judd
Apatow is just on and uh so tune into
that and then uh Sunday papers which I
do with Mike Gibbons uh tour dates
coming up Point Pleasant New Jersey
Uncle Vinnie's and then look for dates
in the fall and I got a new special I
shot at The Comedy Store in the original
room is it out no I'm we're editing it
right now I just gave him the final edit
note so I don't know I guess it's got to
get color corrected and so maybe in like
a month or two it'll come out all right
yeah that's great come back and promote
it please all right thanks man hell yeah
as always Ryan sickler on all social
media Ryan sickler.com we'll talk to you
all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]